So Leute, spielen wir noch ein paar Runden Battlefield.
Wenn man nicht ganz sicher ist, wir spielen erstmal auf dem offiziellen Server eine Runde
und dann gucken wir danach was es für Server in... Moment, Moment.
Oh je, ich hab meinen Sound noch nicht an.
Also, das Ganze nochmal zu wiederholen, danach gucken wir was es für Server in... gibt.
By the way, irgendwie hab ich den Sound viel zu... Oh Alter, ist ja gut, jaja.
Soundtrack 2015, null.
Ne, von wann ist das Game? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Venice and Least. Venice and Least.
Aber Leute, die irgendwie auf dem Server sind, exellent.
Aber vorher müssen wir erstmal schauen, ob Twitch gecheckt hat, dass es 1080p ist.
Nein, noch nicht, ok, da müssen wir kurz warten.
Und wir müssen warten, bis Twitch das gecheckt hat, dass es 1080p streamen darf.
Moin, exlepeng.de
Ich hab das bestimmt absolut nicht richtig ausgesprochen.
Wir müssen kurz warten, bis es auf 1080p switcht.
Der Switcher 3. So, jetzt, wunderbar.
Gehen wir hier hin.
Kann man Nachricht schicken?
So, äh, kann man Leuten joinen, irgendwie in Battlefield? Geht das?
Nope, natürlich nicht. Egal, joinen wir einfach so.
180p ist da, noch ne Runde Cobalt, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Geisterserver, oh, du bist einer der wenigen, der dieses Video geguckt hat.
Das ist uralt, das ist bestimmt schon Jahr alter Geisterserver.
Wobei uralt, uralt ist mein Call of Duty 4 Hacker Video von 2010, das ist uralt.
Video, was ein Jahr ist, ist für Max Verhältnisse ehrlich gesagt noch richtig neu.
Wenn es, gucken wir danach. Wir machen erstmal ne Runde, ne Runde normal.
Und dann, und dann gucken wir uns ein bisschen an.
Nö.
Läuft. Ach komm, jetzt kann man doch nachjoin was.
Das Game weiß nicht Bescheid, alter.
Hast du schon, hast du schon, ja hab ich, hab ich.
Es läuft auch top, kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Läuft top, Server sind gut.
Einzige Sache, die mich jetzt persönlich aktuell ein bisschen stört, ist kein Anti-Cheat.
Aber gut, was machst du?
Machste nix?
So, wo sind, wo ist denn hier der...
Oh, ich muss Team wechseln.
Die müssen mich jetzt, die müssen mich bloß reinlassen.
Die müssen mich reinlassen?
Soll ich mich mal in Squad lassen?
Also, guck mal was hier, was hier auf der...
Was in der Metro los ist.
Exzellent.
Boah, Dauerfeuer.
Dauerfeuer Kevin am Start.
What the fuck?
Mein Handy hat gerade geklingelt.
Ohne zu klingeln, ganz merkwürdig.
Das Handy hat vibriert, ohne zu klingeln.
Und ohne das Display angeht.
Und, und ohne dass überhaupt irgendwas ist.
Ist offen.
Exzellent.
Bei Venis Unleashed musst du...
Du musst nix großartig runterladen für Venis Unleashed.
Ich sag immer noch Venis, das heißt Venice, Alter.
Und ne, eigentlich ehrlich gesagt heißt...
Musst du ein 77 MB Client runterladen.
Das ist aktuell Vanilla Battlefield.
Weil ich da ein paar Leute hab, mit denen ich spielen kann.
Also aktuell musst du 77 MB runterladen.
Ich kann dir das mal zeigen.
Wir können übrigens den Soundtrack mal ausmachen.
Du gehst auf Downloads, das ist nicht groß, 77 MB fertig.
Mehr musst du nicht runterladen.
Du musst aber über Origin das Game runterladen.
Und Battlefield 3 ist glaube ich mit DLCs irgendwie 30, 30G oder so.
30, 35, 40G mit allen DLCs.
Glaube ich so in dem Dreh.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau.
Ja.
Also...
Na ja.
Speicherplatz ist doch heute nicht mehr das Problem.
Ja, Battlefield 4 auf Konsolen ist glaube ich ziemlich dead.
Ja, das seh ich.
Also was ich bei Venice Unleashed wie gesagt aktuell ein bisschen doof finde ist,
dass es kein Anti-Cheat gibt.
Und dass die meisten Server zu groß sind.
Weil es ist ja schön und gut wenn man 120 oder 103er Server hat.
Aber die meisten Maps sind einfach nicht drauf ausgelegt.
Oh, WTF, das Nametag ist nicht reingeladen.
Null W.
Ah, Bam in your face, Alter.
Null.
Voll geschreckt.
Massive schreckt, Alter.
Aber guck mal jetzt, Flankerino Action.
Da geh ich jetzt mit.
Smoke, oh.
Smoke ist raus.
Bam.
Ey, sag mal was ist das?
Das Handy vibriert.
Ach ne.
Ihr werdet mir nicht glauben, was das ist.
Ich pisse mich weg.
Ich pisse mich.
Ihr glaubt es nicht.
Leute, mein Xbox Controller liegt auf dem Tisch.
Der Xbox Controller, den habe ich vorher angeschlossen, weil ich ein anderes Game gespielt habe.
Der liegt auf dem Tisch.
Und der vibriert, wenn ich mit der Maus schieße.
Das ist nicht das Handy.
Das hat mich mega verwirrt.
Mein Tisch hat vibriert, während ich geschossen habe.
Ganz merkwürdig, weißt du?
Oh.
Lell, aber richtig Lell.
Du wusstest, dass es der Controller ist.
Beobachtest du mich über meine Webcam?
GachiBuzz?
Oder woher wusstest du das?
Äh, Hä?
Gegner?
Die Gegner, die lassen sich ja mal extrem bashen.
Warum lassen die sich so bashen, Alter?
Was ist mit denen los?
Hyper bash, Alter.
Hyper bash.
Ist angesagt.
Oh.
Der Fäkalien-Sammler ist auch am Start.
Nice.
Die Gegner haben sich ja gerade bashen lassen des Todes.
Guck mal mein Squad.
9-0-10-1-9-0-8.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Ich will mich aber nicht beschweren.
Was will der?
Ich will mich ja nicht beschweren.
Ich habe lieber Sucker-Gegner.
So ultra-krasse Tryhard-Skill-Best-Matchmaking-Dudes.
Wo ist denn der...
Wo ist denn hier der...
Der El-Schmago-Fatz?
Das ist er nicht.
Das ist er auch nicht.
Oh.
Wo ist hier was, wo ist hier was?
Post-Champ, Post-Champ, Post-Champ.
Wo wollt ihr denn lang, Jungs?
Geradeaus?
Rechts?
Okay, sieht aus wie rechts.
Ich stelle es mal mit.
MonkaS.
Immer schön, immer schön ratzen.
Der Rats-Train ist ja am Start hier in Battlefield 3.
So, wir campen uns jetzt mal eins mal schön hier einen ab.
Kommt, kommt.
Die Kleinen stellts aus, kommt um die Ecke.
Au.
Nein, nein, nein.
In Ruhe lassen, lass mich nur.
Bashen, alter, bashen.
Okay, da kommt nichts.
Null.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was mich hier gerade anschießt.
Oh, oh, ein Kerl aus der Metro.
Wir gehen aber gut durch hier, sagt nichts.
Ist Venice an Leash gefloppt?
Na ja, von gefloppt kann man prinzipiell ja bei solchen Projekten nicht sprechen.
Gefloppt würde ja bedeuten, es hat deutlich mehr gekostet, als es eingebracht hat.
Und das ist natürlich nicht der Fall.
Aber nein, aber auch in Spielersinns hat es nicht gefloppt.
Ich hab vorhin geguckt, du hattest irgendwie, wie nicht, 100, 150 Spiele oder so.
Ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Moin, Max, als wär ich revealed, Leute.
Ich bin, wir wurden enttarnt.
Seht ihr's im Chat, wir wurden enttarnt.
Oh, fuck, das wär ein Gegner, null.
Null, W.
Okay, mal mal Flank Action.
Okay, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo hier was kommt.
Aber nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Lass mich in Ruhe, Alter, lass mich.
Lass mich.
Lull, ich wusste es, dass du mir nachrennst, Alter.
Get schreckt, get schreckt.
Wir gehen gut durch, durch die Metro, ne?
Lass uns das mal kurz Captchern.
Rechts ist einer, direkt rechts.
Ja, natürlich.
Wen trifft der, wenn ich über die Tonne spring?
Natürlich mich.
Kommst du raus?
Oh nee, da oben ist einer.
Der Plaufilter.
Ganz ehrlich, ich find zwar das Spiel sieht viel moderner und letztendlich auch besser aus.
Also ohne Plaufilter.
Aber der Plaufilter ist einfach Battlefield 3.
Ich seh nix.
Lull, Leute, ich hab aufgehört zu schießen, weil ich gedacht hab easy ist der tot, easy
ist der tot.
Aber der ist nicht tot und schon gar nicht easy.
Okay, der Red Strain ist am Start.
Mächtiger, mächtiger Red Strain.
Okay, ich glaub jetzt können wir.
Ich glaub wir können, ich glaub wir können.
Warte mal, ich rush jetzt vor.
Fuck, zu viele.
Oh, oh, oh.
Grenade.
Okay, jetzt wird es mir ein bisschen viel hier auf einmal.
Hier haben wir geplantet.
Lege Hände am Start.
Da sind sie drinne, ich seh euch.
Leute, ihr wollt da rauskommen, ich weiß.
Das ist ja krass, wie die gebashed werden.
Die werden ja hardcore gebashed.
Oh, oh, oh, what?
Ach, hinter mir.
Lull.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich hab den nicht gesehen am Anfang.
Sag mal, sag mal, warum lassen die sich so übertrieben bashen gerade?
Haben die sich gedacht, der Max braucht ein Weihnachtsgeschenk, Alter.
Macht mal, lasst, lasst euch mal in the ass bashen, ey.
Die kriegen so, die kriegen ja grad sowas von ein rein.
Wahnsinn.
Aber man muss auch sagen, wir haben auch richtig gutes Team.
Das macht was auch, oh nein, danach kommt Grand Bazaar.
Clusterfuck of Doom.
Ja, links ist doch, war doch eben noch irgendwas.
Ich mach jetzt den Yolo jetzt hier.
Einmal across the map.
Team Balance wäre mal gut.
Ach, was, wer braucht Team Balance, Alter?
Team Balance, Team Balance ist overrated.
Nein, nein, das ist keine Weihnacht Snoups, die Gegner sind gar nicht sooo schlecht, aber das Team ist gut.
Okay easy, easy, wo ist ja was?
Whoa, Schneibers.
Schneibers am Start.
unter mir ist ein toter weiß aber nicht genau
ach du er lebt schon wieder alles klar ich hab nichts gesagt
ok das war das war ein bisschen zu übermütig aber krass aber ich krieg den retz hier massive
big brain place leute big brain place der ingo oder oder wie heißt der typ da hinten
schon wieder übersehen das ist halt echt das geile an battlefield 3 ne permanent permanent
ist hier irgendwas am explodieren um dich und es ist es ist halt immer immer mitten mitten in
der action so jetzt müssen wir irgendwie flankerino machen massiv nein alter erst
vereimt und dann in your face in the ass alter ja da krieg ich kein retz jetzt das kann ich
nicht erwarten soll das funken aber nice guck mal so haben sie hier schön reingehockt ins haus
ich glaube die wollen gar nicht legen ich glaube die wollen einfach gegner im spawn
farmen kann das sein einfach gegner farmen und gar nicht killen und gar nicht runde gewinnen
einfach gegner abfahren alter den will ich haben wo ist er streckt einen kopf raus alter
streckt den kopf raus irgendwo dahinter ist er da ist er hier guckt ja der sagt der denkt
ich habe wallhack oder sowas das war bush bang oh ach nee das weihnachtstour mit dem
friseur ich habe noch nichts aufgenommen mit fabian wir haben auch gesagt es wird zu knapp
easy win die runde war wirklich easy wir haben gesagt es wird zu knapp wir haben am 23
haben wir noch kurz im discord und da abgesprochen zu und haben festgestellt es wird nichts mehr
alter was eine runde ja das weiß ich auch nicht warum die tag light spielen gerade gerade
bei der aktuelle pet stand aktuelle pet stand es gibt gegen battlefield 3 kann aktuellen
pet stand also gerade beim letzten beim jetzt aktuellen und für immer aktuell bleibenden
pet stand von battlefield 3 da sind die tag lights kacke könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern
wie wie krass op die tag lights am anfang waren wenn man in die metro gegangen ist und
ich hatte einer durch den kompletten gang vom spawn aus angeschaut und ein ganzer bildschirm
war denn ein weiß-blauer ring das war das war noch was ok clusterfuck bazaar was sind
wir defender attacker defender muss man glaub sein oh attack jetzt gibt's auf den sack
jetzt gibt's auf den sack cover please oh shit ja mach ich dann mach ich dann ach dann
cover wir brauchen cover ohne cover sacked au was ist hier los da ist aber nur einer
den kriegen wir easy was das war nicht der kill ich glaube es geht los ich hab dem grad
20 schuss reingeklatscht erstmal runde medic und ich hole den anderen auch noch oh alter
die haben auf den sack gekriegt oh nee shit ich dachte wir kriegen's oh in your face mit
der shotgun der retz train ja beste beste retz train so muss das sein komm komm um die
ecke alter kommst du um die ecke please ecke ecken stellts ok die sind schon tot bevor
ich auf was machen kann was sag ich mit der map da unten seit wann ist die so klein ah
schon immer ist die map da unten schon immer so klein leute nee oder das stimmt doch was
nicht das ist jetzt grad nicht wenn es anliegt das ist normal warum ist die map so mini seht
ihr das miniatur map alter du siehst du auch nicht wo die wo die begrenzung ist oder pence
man ist am starte mit n ja moment ach ernsthaft warum weiß ich das nicht warum warum kenne
ich das nicht warum warum ist mir das nicht bekannt dass man das machen kann chat warum
habt ihr mir das noch nicht früher gesagt warum wusste ich das nicht die spieler spieler
zählen ja ich wusste es nicht der lebt noch der duit etzer tot in face in your face alter
Lass mich raus, ich muss den Burger man wieder beleben
Nicht plocken, siehste plocken ist scheiße, plocken suckt
Ey das game, das game macht mich verrückt gerade
Guck dir mal den Squad an, die sind richtig gut
Guck dirs mal
Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Da gibt's in your face
Battlefield lag, geil, ich wollte den Tank rein spawnen, ich klick auf Dings, will switchen, nice
Der Chat, der Chat wird da, loop in tank, only good in tank
Hahahaha
Hauptsache, Hauptsache mach nen Typ der frischen zu, einfach mal geflamed, ja
Einfach mal geflamed
Ok, Repairman am Start
Excellent, Repairman, Massive Runde, ich seh schon kommen hier, High IQ, High Spannungsrunde
Oh, oh, nein, von hinten, in the ass, Alter, Bjot, Bjot
Alter, lass dich doch nicht bashen, ey, muss mal hier weg, muss mal hier weg, Tank
Alter, ah, Pantsman, kannst nix machen, fuck, voll reingerannt, dann geh ich noch
Also Panzer, ich würde dich ja rappen, ja, was haben die Maids für Level, ach die sind alle
Big Brain Level, 500 IQ sind die alle, die brauchen mich gar nicht zum rappen, guck mal,
es ist eigentlich vollkommen overrated, dass ich rappe, keiner muss rappen, auf, auf, muss
die bashen, Alter, Pantsman Turret, ich muss ein bisschen aufholen, es kann nicht sein,
dass ich erst 4 Kills hab, die haben ja noch nie mehr 19, ne, jaja, wo sind sie, Repairn
sich die Tanks eigentlich von alleine, ich glaub mit der Zeit Repairn die sich von alleine
die Tanks, ne, ne, keine Level 1, die Noobwelle ist vorbei, die Noobwelle hat sich erledigt,
wobei das gar nicht unbedingt sein muss, es könnte ja sein, ich hab ja in Weihnachten
auch nicht reingeguckt, es könnte ja sein, dass es noch welche gibt, die jetzt an Weihnachten
spielen, ich mein das Game ist immerhin auch kostenlos, sag mal, ach da sind Gegner drin,
sagt mir das doch einer, lull, okay, kommt her, bashen, Alter, bashen, seh nix, kommt
auf die Gas, kommt auf die Gas und lasst euch bashen, sind die gelieft, ich glaub die sind
alle gelieft, die haben alle keinen Bögel mehr, Auto in die Luft jagen, Wärm, ach,
ich muss aussteigen, ich hab den Javelin mit meinem Körper abgefangen, Javelin, warum
hat man hier nen Javelin bei, weiß es nicht, naja gut, das letzte kriegen wir auch so,
ich sollte halt vielleicht nicht unbedingt hier als Engie jetzt am Start sein, okay,
wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt was ganz verpöntes Leute, RPG on Inf, RPG on Inf,
passt auf, ah fuck, oh, Alter, okay, wir machen doch kein RPG on Inf, wir spawnen jetzt,
wir spawnen jetzt rein als Soldat wieder, guck mal mein Team, Alter, mein Team, bam,
bam, geht durch, okay, Pantsman ist wieder am Start gleich, nice, wo ist hier was, hallo,
ich seh nix, aber die könnten jetzt von links gleich kommen, wir sollten eigentlich Legehenne
machen, oder zumindest wir können eigentlich legen, da hinten war was, da hinten war was,
auf der anderen Seite, bam, oh Mist, ich dachte er stirbt jetzt, wir müssen das, das
Amp kommen, Alter, wir brauchen das Amp kommen, wir müssen einfach nur das Amp kommen im Blick
behalten, easy, Roadban, Alter, wir werden, wir werden das Cheat, das Cheatens, das, das
Cheatens-Gevote-Band, Alter, was ist hier los, hast du schon ein Visier für die P90,
wahrscheinlich, ich hab letzter Zeit recht viel P90 gespielt, sehen wir gleich, aber
gut, ich hab viel P90 gespielt, aber nicht viel engineered, das heißt insgesamt, insgesamt
sein auch nicht viel P90, skip, guck mal mal, das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich in BF3 nie
verstanden hab, warum konnte man während der Runde kein Equipment ändern, BF3-Klassik,
ja danach gucken wir mal ein bisschen, ich spiele jetzt noch ein paar Runden, ich spiele
jetzt noch mal eine Runde Defender-Bazaar und dann spielen wir noch mal eine Runde vielleicht
auf Metro und dann guck ich mal in, in, nein, ja das kenn ich, also man kann kein Battlefield-Stream
gucken und gleichzeitig spielen, dann ist man, dann denkt man immer von Sichtseiten sind
Gegner dabei, ist es im Stream und so, guck mal wie es abgeht, Cheat, Cheat, nooo, das
ist nicht so, oh, lol, lol, w alter, Cosplay, nee, warum soll Cosplay gehen, das ist im Game
10 Jahre nichts getan ey, MonkaS, was ist hier los, alter, alter, Monka, ist ja gut ey,
ich mach schon Rats Action, ok hier kommt keiner durch, alter ich sag's euch, hier kommt keiner
durch, hier kommt keiner durch, ey, die Gegner machen es aber nicht blöd, oh nee, nein, alter,
die sollen unser Team nicht bannen, was soll das, außerdem, die cheaten auch nicht, ich
hab letztes Mal schon mit denen gespielt, die Gegner haben einfach nur gesagt, ok, erstmal
paar Nades rüberhauen, können wir vor, oh nee Leute, wenn wir hier vorgehen, das artet,
das artet in Spawn Rape aus, oh fuck, ok das, oh nee, nee, nee Leute, oh, oh, oh, oh,
Bazaar Spawn Rape Position am Start, oh nee, ich ahne Schlimmes, ich ahne Schlimmes, oh
nee, was die haben gelegt, was ist hier los, die Legehänne, die Legehänne ist ran, die
Legehänne, ich fass es nicht, ich, ich clear hinten, null, alles was hinten spawnen kriegt
von mir auf den Zack, aber hinten spawnen nichts mehr, fuck, die sind wirklich, die
sind wirklich aggressive, die Gegner, nee, jetzt, nee, nee, ich fass es nicht, oh, wir
sind, wir sind ziemlich, ziemlich sandwich, scheisse, ziemlich gesandwiched, oh shit,
Rush Meat Grinder, aber die Gegner sind, die sind gut durchgepusht, wir hatten eigentlich
die Spawn Rape Position am Start, aber da machst du nichts, jetzt kommen die auch noch,
hä, von wo ist der Typ gestorben, hä, what the hell, warum sehen die das, ach du Massive
Nade, Massive Nade, Big Brain Nades hier am Start, ok, jetzt kommen wir vor, jetzt,
jetzt Spawn Rape Position am Start, beste, beste Position, passt mal auf, beste Position,
beste Position ist übrigens nicht hier, nee, nur mal so angemerkt, beste Position ist nicht
hier, nee, nee, nee, nee, beste Position ist auch nicht hier, beste Position ist hinter
dem Auto, hinter dem Auto, da, genau da, genau da, genau hier hinter dem Auto, hinter dem
Auto ist Pog, richtig, Pog ist hinter dem Auto, einfach nur Pog, leicht unfaire Position,
die wir hier haben, minimal unfaire, so leicht, ganz leicht unfaire, jetzt haben, die Gegner
sind schon wieder durch in der Mitte, ich fasse es nicht, ppg, ein A-Aimed, fuck, das
ist aktuell noch Vanilla, das ist noch Vanilla, Norscher, was, was haben wir, drei, eh, Damavent
Peak, Alter, Damavent Peak, Damavent Peak, beste, wir müssen auf die andere Seite gucken,
die kommen, please, Grand Bazaar, ey, das ist wieder, halt, naja, gut, was willst du
machen, das ist halt so eine typische Grand Bazaar Runde, Opulte, Rättspunkte auf Doom,
wo sind sie, wo sind sie, was habe ich denn gevotet, habe ich Damavent Peak gevotet,
ich hoffe schon, oh, what, Alter, bam, ba, ba, bam, 3 STX, erstmal schön durch Smoke
und alles durchspotten, komm, ich will, wenn ich schon nicht viel Kills gemacht habe,
ich will den letzten Kill machen, die haben gelegt, die Legehänne ist am Start, fuck,
schnell, ah, die Legehänne hat sich rumgeschlichen, die Legehänne hat sich reingeschlichen, ok,
easy, easy Legehänne, MVP am Start, jawoll, hui, das war aber knapp, das hätte nochmal
ins Auge gehen können, das hätte nochmal ins Auge gehen können, kann man, ne, ich
probiere es jetzt nicht aus, ich probiere es jetzt nicht aus, ob man parallel zu Battlefield
3 starten kann, guck mal, ich kriege mein eigenes Video empfohlen, nice, ich bin übrigens
richtig, richtig froh, dass das so gut angekommen ist, das Video, ich meine 350 Comments, 27.000
nach irgendwie 3 Tagen jetzt, für ein Video, was ich ja normalerweise überhaupt nicht
sonst auf dem Channel mache, alter, mein Team trete auf, oder, ich bin heute aber auch schon
ein bisschen durch den Wind, erstmal ein bisschen hier ausreden, dass man nicht top fragt, auch
mal Defender, haben wir nicht, haben wir nicht gerade schon defendet, aber auch kein Floor,
da kommt gleich einer links, excellent, oh, wir müssen jetzt gucken, dass die links nicht
durchstelsen, aha, knapp, knapp, knapp, close, echt, komm, nicht dass die links durch, links,
okay, okay, okay, wir müssen links, nein, ich habe da so reingeholzt, wie konnte er
noch pieken, nice, okay, frag ist durch, das ist natürlich schwierig, die da wieder raus
zu kriegen, einfach mal durch, einfach mal durch, okay, da können die mich nicht mal
retzen, ich habe es schon mal probiert, ich wollte einfach mal, da ist ja halb Russland
vor der Tür, da ist wirklich halb Russland vor der Tür gerade, guckt euch das mal an,
oder die halbe USA ist vor der Tür, ich glaube die USA ist das, ich glaube wir sind die Russen,
oder, sind wir die Russen, ich glaube wir sind die Russen, ich glaube wir sind die Russen,
Alter, weggesprayt jetzt, planten die gerade, waren die gerade, plant a Reno, ja habe ich
ein nade, habe ich ein nade, nice, nice, die kommt gut, die kommt gut rein, man sieht ja
gar nichts, guckt euch das mal an, vor lauter gespamme, massive, massive nade, jetzt kommen
die auch noch mit C4 an, haben sie gesagt, Granaten spam reicht nicht, wir brauchen
noch C4 spam, wo sind die gestorben, meine Jungs hier, kann ich nicht rein, geht nicht,
keine Chance, oh fuck die sind durch, Mist, Mist, Mist, ich habe es noch probiert, ich
wollte noch rein, ich wollte noch rein, ich dachte ich kriege den plant da vielleicht,
aber nope, Kerngedanke ist rein, so muss man es machen, kann man das nicht, nein das kannst
du nicht, Mösern, da ist ein Dach drüber, oh man, aufgepasst, da oben liegt er, sag
plus die kriegen jetzt tatsächlich ein Objective, wusste gar nicht, dass es dich noch gibt,
ja ja, mich gibt es immer noch, auch wenn letztens jemand lustig sein wollte und geschrieben
hat, hallo du bist noch nicht an Corona verreckt, xD, xD natürlich, xD, ihr wisst ja wenn ihr
was dummes schreibt, wenn ihr was richtig dummes schreibt und euch selbst beim Schreiben
auffällt, dass es dumm ist, dann müsst ihr einfach xD dahinter machen, dann ist es easy,
dann ist es kein Problem mehr, so nach dem Modo Chat, ihr seid die dümmsten Kacknoobs
auf der Welt, xD, solange mal xD macht es alles gut, xD, xD war klar, dass der Chat
jetzt mitmacht, ich gehe mal kurz rüber zu meinen Jungs, da werde ich auch mal ein paar
Kills abkriegen, weil der erste schon 20 Kills hat, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD,
xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD, xD,
xD, easy, easy win, aber es ist gleich vorbei, nur 30 Tickets, ok ich gehe jetzt mal auf
meine POG Position, POG Position, guckt euch mal an POG Position, seht ihr die POG Position!?
Nicht die Pole Position, das ist die POG Position man, seht ihr jetzt POG Position, Metro
Kark, T-Theran, Highway, Beste.
Haben wir nicht schon für grad Demavan Peak gewaltet?
Lul, weh, Alter.
Oh, jetzt wollen sie's wissen.
Jetzt wären sie advanced, jetzt kommen sie mit Smoke an.
Jetzt wird, oh Mist, jetzt wird auch noch gesmokt.
Wie lange machst du schon YouTube, äh, seit 2010?
Okay, wir müssen weg.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht sterben.
Monka.
Okay, da kommt gleich links einer.
Den Dude links werden wir jetzt bashen.
Ah nee, das ist mein, das ist mein LMG Dude, der da ballert, okay.
Ich guck da doch nicht durch.
Gute Alte, Grand Bazaar, Spawn Rape, super, beste Runden, Residenz Leaper.
Der Core Game ist 97, den, gegen den hab ich auch schon ein paar Mal gespielt, der ist
auch echt gut.
Der, der one tapped alles mit ein, 94, across the map, ja, M16 ist die beste Waffe in dem
Game.
Hast du den Artikel gelesen zum Battlefield 3 Remake, nee, wo, hab ich nicht, hab ich
nicht, wobei ich ganz ehrlich der Meinung bin, ich will gar kein Battlefield 3 Remake,
ich will nen, gutes Battlefield 6, vor allem wann sollen die da bitteschön das Battlefield
3 Remake releasen?
Wenn 2021 wirklich, wirklich Battlefield, Battlefield 6 kommt, wann sollen die das dann
raushauen?
Metro schon, boah, na gut, okay, okay wir gehen uns noch ne Runde Metro, ist okay, ist
okay.
Weil, weil, weil, Chet, weil ihr seid, gehen wir uns noch ne Runde Metro, easy, easy win.
Ich hätte jetzt ja gar gerne Demoman Peak gespielt oder Terran Highway oder irgendwas
anderes außer, außer Grand Bazaar und Metro, okay, let's go, let's go, oh da kommt links
was?
Leute, das müsst ihr erstmal machen, lege Henne, Achtung, lege Henne, retz Henne plus,
plus Gegner killen, oh fuck, das alles auf einmal gerade, habt ihr das gesehen?
Richtig Massive, lege Henne, gekillt und, und gerätzt, mach den, mach den platt, Alter
mach den platt, nein, die haben diffused mann, okay, push, push, push, push, push, push,
best, best, er hat 20 capable
He he he
Beste Posi Leute, beste Posi
Lull
Ey lass was übrig
Alter lass was übrig
NEIN
Warum bin ich jetzt komplett dead
Metro Rush Beste
Huge, huge
Ja, also wie gesagt wenn ihr einen Link habt zum Artikel
Äh, wurde ich gerade geswitcht?
Ich wurde gerade geswitcht?
Ich will nicht darüber, ich will ja nicht auf den Sack kriegen
Cybermobbing
Feels bad
Warum switcht mich der Server
Jetzt fühle ich mich aber echt hier
Benachteiligt von dem Game
Harassed Alter
So jetzt probier mal wenn es unleashed aus
Ich hab keinen Bock auf den Sack zu kriegen gegen die Gegner ey
Balance, ja ich weiß dass es Balance war
Aber ich wollte nicht gebalanced werden
Die sollen jemand anderes balancen
Ey guck mal wenn es unleashed rein
Was es da gibt
Ok, ah hier Twitter, was?
GamePro
Zu den Lowbobs geswitcht genau
Ich hab hier extra in Origen geguckt
Dass wir zusammen ins Team kommen
So
Battlefield 3 Remaster
Durch mysteriösen ey
Mysteriös
Ist so eines der
Der clickbait
Wörter des Jahres
Ich hab so viele YouTube Titels gesehen wo was von mysteriös drin steht
Mit der Aug
Ja vielleicht heute aber mit der Aug
Also
Deutet Electronic Arts zwar ein Remaster
Von Battlefield 3
Hä
Was ist denn
Und
Das Twitter Inhalt
Erlauben
Hä
Das ist doch
Ok wenn das ein Teaser
Für Battlefield 3 Remaster ist
Dann
Wisst ihr was das dumme ist
Eigentlich
Ist ein Battlefield 3 Remaster überhaupt
Nicht notwendig
Was willst du denn bitte schön an Battlefield 3
Großartig remastern
Als vom 11.9. guck mal die News sind doch
Uralt
Da kommt nichts und wenn
Das nur um alte Leute abzufischen
Ohne Sinn und Verstand
Was willst du denn im Game großartig remastern
Kennst du dich mit den Temperaturen
Das Spannungswandler auf dem Mainboard aus
Was der für Temperaturen so ab kann
Ich würd sagen
Sobald der anfängt zu klühen ist definitiv zu warm
Was haben wir hier
Zen Crossing TDM
Oh Rush wir haben tatsächlich
Server
Ich spiel doch kein
Venice Unleashed um dann Notch
A Candles TDM zu spielen
Gunmaster
Spectate
Warte mal Gunmaster
Was war denn das nochmal
War Gunmaster die
Geschichte wo du alle Waffen
Durchswitched
Warte
Die bleu ich jetzt mit der Spass
Moment ist das die Rex
Ich glaub schon oder
Und wie ging das nochmal
Musste man 3 Kills machen
Oder wie ist das nochmal
Ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern
Jetzt schreckt
Moment
Wenn ich das jetzt aufhebe
Was passiert dann
Wenn ich jetzt bei Gunmaster einfach die Waffe aufhebe
Ist es dann kaputt
Und by the way man sieht keine Gegner da drauf
Oh KS
Man müsst halt mit der
Man bräuchte eine gescheite Waffe
Und nicht wenn alle hier schon mit SMG und sonst was
Rumrennen
Mit der geilen Pistel man
Und by the way ist leckt
Da ist er jetzt wird er gebashed
Warum hat der erste Schuss schon wieder nicht gehitted
Habt ihrs gesehen der erste Schuss war komplett drauf
Ich bin zu dumm für die Waffe
Die hat so eine leichte Verzögerung
Ich komm damit überhaupt nicht klar
Gib big brain Leute
Die gehen damit voll ab
Aber ich nicht
Ich nicht ich kann das nicht
Null
Ist das die Spaß
Spaß Alter
Spaß
Aber so was voll in die Shotgun
So was voll in your face
Geschottgun
Shotgun
War das auch nur shotgun
War das auch nur shotgun ich kenne die ganzen waffen nicht mehr. Ich meine ich spiele nur m416
Kann ich
Äh, wat, wat the hell, please explain game
Die kommen jetzt gleich heraus, die wollen mich bashen aber ich werde sie bashen
Sag mal die die also die shotgun ist ja mal mega mies alter habt ihr das gesehen
Da stirbt ja gar nix
Richtig schlecht, alter sucker gun, richtige sucker gun
Kommt her
Ist das normal dass man hier kein kit hat? Ich glaube schon ne also es gibt hier keine midi packs und sowas
Habe ich das richtig in erinnerung ja
Weil ansonsten hätte ich gern midi packs
Balkon stellts, Balkon stellts wo sind die Gegner? Gegner kommt her ich will euch bashen
In der S gefuckt, okay es gibt kein midi pack alles klar
Ich, aber das macht
Macht voll Bock wenn man am Anfang sag mal so wenn man seit Anfang an dabei ist dann halt ne
Hallo?!, Please game, please!
Ohhh, wat, wie ist denn der da durch geht
Game, please.
Oh, oh! What? Wie ist denn der da durchgekommen?
Ach so, ich hab'n 146er Ping.
Ach, deswegen fühlt sich das so komisch an.
Deswegen fühlt sich das so laggy und komisch an.
Und es geht nix rein, stirbt nix.
Jetzt versteh' ich, jetzt ergibt's Sinn.
Okay, okay, okay, jetzt ergibt es Sinn, alles klar.
Also, ich bin hyping Bob jetzt.
Easy.
Guck, du kannst, du gewinnst keine Zweikämpfe mehr.
Okay, mit dem Ping ist es aber echt mies, ja.
Der Karlsrund, 15 Monate lang, ist schon für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Hypersubscription ist das schon.
Äh, okay, alles klar.
Äh, was zum Geier war das nochmal, eine G3, ne?
G3 mit dem hässlichsten Style aller Zeiten.
Alter, wer spielt denn sowas?
Man guckt euch das mal an.
Ist doch nicht normal.
Wer spielt denn so ne Waffe?
Keck!
Tribble you, hab'n, ich hab'n den noch einmal gesehen.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, da ist ein Shotgun Dude.
Shotgun Dude hier am Start.
Ah, von hinten, alles klar.
ACOG so useless, aber richtig.
Richtiges useless ACOG Visier.
Guck mal, wie man um die, Alter, wie man hier um die Ecke gebashed wird mit dem Ping, ist ja...
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie ist Battlefield mit nem 120, äh, mit nem 140er oder 100...
Ja, 140er, 150er Ping zu spielen.
Da komm' ich mir hervor, wie in CS zu Moda im Zeiten.
ACOG, genau.
Jawoll.
Du hörst den Gegner und bist instant weg.
In Hardcore, ja, aber nur in Hardcore.
Krasse Head-Clitch-Stalls am Start ist und sonst nix.
Kann man spotten in dem Mode?
Was ist das, Scar? Scar?
Was ist das, Scar?
Poggers? Poggers Scar?
Was ist denn Poggers?
Scar, Scar Pog?
Okay, ich hab' den nicht gesehen.
Scar Pog ist das, nice.
Scar ist total underrated Waffe in dem Game.
Ich find' die ehrlich gesagt...
Ich find' die richtig cool.
Also, wenn das die, wenn das die, ähm...
Die Medic-Waffe ist.
Die schießt zwar total langsam,
aber es macht trotzdem Bock.
Also, ich würd' sagen, an sich ist die...
Guck mal.
Level 9. Fields Batman.
Pepehands.
Okay, geben wir...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das nochmal gebe.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir nochmal...
nochmal 140er Ping gebe.
Aber Gungame, bzw.
der Modus macht Bock.
In BR4 ist gar nichts OP.
Äh...
In Belfin 4 war, glaub' ich,
AC23 und
ACWR übelst OP.
Ja.
Skyhawk, das könnt sein.
Weil's sehr anstrengend ist,
mit 150er Ping zu spielen.
Wisst ihr, was für einen Vorteil
das Battlelog hatte?
Jetzt mal so ganz ohne Spaß.
Du konntest den Battlelog einfach schon parallel,
während das geladen hat, nach einem weiteren Server suchen.
Gibt auch einen Gungame-Server in DE.
Aber da ist keiner drauf, oder?
Ich hab nach Spieler sortiert und das war der einzige Gungame-Server.
Hallo?
Postchamp?
Die Usas mit Feuerammo. Könnt ihr euch noch an die Beta-UMP erinnern?
Across the Map,
so One-Shot-Headshots so nach dem Motto.
Die UMP war krass in der Beta.
Okay Leute, ich glaub' das Game ist gecrasht
oder der Server ist gecrasht oder...
oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Okay, schießen wir das Ganze mal ab, starten's neu.
Nee, Battlelog-Server bringt mir ja nix.
Der hier war spielen.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch für Auswahl?
Okay, der Server ist gerade gecrasht.
Ich glaub' das war der, oder?
Ich glaub' der hat den Runden-Neustart nicht überlegt.
Okay, ich hab' den Runden-Neustart nicht überlegt.
Ich hab' den Runden-Neustart nicht überlegt.
Okay, Kark Island TDM.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich spiel' doch nicht den Mod, um da
Nosha Canals und Grand Bazaar TDM zu spielen, ey.
Rush Nightmaps, oh cool.
Nice.
Das spielen wir jetzt, Rush Nightmaps.
Oh, der Server hat'n bisschen hohen Ping.
99999er Ping.
Monka Shake.
Okay Leute, ich bin gespawnt.
Ich bin gespawnt, aber es ist kaputt.
Excellent.
Monka Greenscreen.
Okay, dann starten wir's nochmal neu.
Also.
Äh.
Ja.
Excellent, ja, richtig.
Ah.
Guck mal, das sieht schon besser.
Nightmaps. Oh, Grand Bazaar in Nacht.
Oh, das ist cool.
Game?
Oh, wieder 100-140er Ping.
Ah, nice Rain Effects.
Postchamp?
Oh, die hab' ich nicht installiert.
Ich glaub', ich hab' kein DLC installiert.
Oder doch, doch, ich muss ja.
Was ist denn jetzt los, Server?
Ha, toll, sehr gut.
Funktioniert ja exquisite.
Ja, super.
TDM, TDM.
Nightmaps.
Alter, was ist das denn?
Okay, das ist übelst kaputt, man.
Ich will, ich will eine Nightmap sehen.
Ohne Scheiß, wir suchen jetzt mal eine Nightmap.
Ich will sehen, wie das aussieht.
Es gab in Battlefield 3, glaub' ich, nur diese eine Panzermap, die nachts gespielt hat.
Dabei ist das was eine richtig coole Sache.
Okay, wo war jetzt hier Nightmaps?
Okay, ist kaputt.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob es irgendwo was anderes noch in Dunkel gibt.
Ich meine, da ist ja sogar der Modern Warfare Nachtmodus besser.
Und das heißt schon was.
Stimmt, Terran Highwall wäre auch nachts.
Aber Terran Highwall war ziemlich hell.
So, wo haben wir Nightmaps?
Also schauen wir mal.
Kann man hier nach Night?
Nighttime.
Ah, die Cocomodates sind da.
Grand Bazaar Team Deathmatch Nighttime.
Technik, die begeistert hier, aber Massive.
Es ist Grand Bazaar-Nacht.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Richtig echter Grand Bazaar-Nacht.
Und das sieht eigentlich richtig cool aus.
Guck mal, auch mit den Lampen hier und so.
Richtig poggers.
Äh, warum ist da gerade hinter mir einfach einer gestorben?
What the fuck?
Hä? Sollte hier nicht einer rennen?
Doch, da war noch einer, oder?
Boah, M26 start.
Auk, soll ich echt mal Auk spielen?
Okay, für den Chat.
Wo ist das Ding überhaupt?
Vor allem, was hab ich mit der Auk denn überhaupt aus?
Equipped, Loadout, Auk, Accessories, also.
Codera Visier.
Forkrip, Heavy Barrel.
Island.
All der Auk.
Sagt man.
Es sind aber Nachtmaps, find ich cool.
Wir spielen jetzt ja mal hier ein bisschen auf Nachtmaps.
Oh fuck man, ich dachte, der ist über mir.
Der war nicht über mir, shit.
Ich wusste, dass der Typ da irgendwie rumstellst.
Press Killstreak-Button.
Ach, das ist auch ein Server mit Killstreaks.
Jetzt kommen die Battlefield-Puristen, die sagen, das ist nicht mehr Battlefield.
Alter, ich seh die Gegner nicht.
Seht ihr die?
Ich seh die nicht.
No chance, ich seh da nix.
Alter, das sieht ja mal gar nix.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, wenn du auf die Gegner schießt, du siehst nichts.
Ohne Scheiß.
Du siehst nix.
Der Wahnsinn.
Mit der MP5 von da unten, alles klar.
Okay, okay, wir müssen adapten.
Es gab doch ein Nachtsichtgerät, oder?
Gab es nicht ein Nachtsichtgerät in dem Spiel?
Was ist denn davon?
Das ist das Nachtsichtgerät.
Alter.
Ey, das Nachtsichtgerät.
Da kommst du ja fast schon wie ein Cheater vor mit dem Nachtsichtgerät.
Kein Gewinn.
Oh nee, nee, nee.
Nein, Gott.
Nein, Gott, bitte nein.
Nein.
RIP.
Leute, und Shadowplay ist auch RIP.
Shadowplay ist auch kaputt.
Aber ich hab's ja zum Glück im Stream, ne?
Ich hab's ja zum Glück im Stream.
Wie gesagt, Mods aus dem Appdater Ordner löschen.
Hä?
Warum?
Okay, okay.
Appdater?
Also, wo muss ich hin?
Battlefield?
Nee.
EA?
Dice?
Venice?
Irgendjemand hat's doch gepostet im Chat eben.
Appdater Local?
Venice Unleashed?
Mods?
Alles klar.
Easy.
By the way, warum geht man Shadowplay nicht mehr?
Kann mir das irgendjemand schlüssig erklären, warum ist Shadowplay jetzt gerade kaputt?
Ah, jetzt geht's Shadowplay wieder, oder wie?
Oder was?
Hä?
Ja.
Okay, Servers. Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Nee, wir müssen Server auf Night machen.
Night.
Ach nee, nicht Game Mods.
Hacks.
Night.
Lul, die ersten Feuerwerksdudes sind schon am Start, gerade draußen bei uns auf der Straße.
Grand Bazaar TDM.
Streamst du über das GeForce Programm?
Nein, nein, ich stream über OBS.
Aber ich mach die Aufnahme über Shadowplay.
Nein, die Festplatte ist auch nicht voll.
Guckt, die Festplatte ist nicht voll.
Auch?
Gucken wir mal, Customize.
Oder?
Okay, da hat's nix gemerkt.
Ich mein, Selbstfall.
Oh.
Nachtsichtgerät kaputt?
Von hinten, ey.
Ist das das richtige Nachtsichtgerät, was?
Oder sehbar, der Cute Mod ist da.
Aber mit dem Ping ist schon ätzend.
Wobei das Nachtsichtding doch schon recht OP ist.
Alter, Kollege, geh weg.
Das Nachtsichtding, Alter.
Okay, jetzt nehmen wir mal kurz auf.
Okay, also eins ist sicher, Nachtsichtgerät ist OP as fuck.
Nachtsichtgerät ist OP as fuck.
Nachtsichtgerät kackt mich, biss mich weg.
Ach, das ist meiner.
Hoho, MonkaS.
Oh nein, mit der Nate, mit dem Granatenwerfer oben auch noch.
Okay, bester Spawn.
Kickass Spawn.
Ja, das sackt aber.
Okay, gucken wir uns die Details an.
Nicht Sticky Notes, Alter, geh weg.
Windows, äh, äh, Windows, äh, äh.
Was, was steht da drinnen?
Aha, alles klar, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Ja, das ist natürlich doof.
Da kann das auch richtig Spaß machen, der Modus, ne.
Aber, ja, was bringt's einem, wenn das crasht nach 5 Minuten?
Nix, ne.
Kann man grad gespielt, den Filter muss man auch immer neu setzen.
Nein, total.
Wir probieren's nochmal.
Der Mod funktioniert ja super, ja.
Massive Mod.
Es macht ultra Bock, ja.
Es macht richtig Bock.
Customize, Appearance, nein, nein, nicht Appearance, Alter.
Wo ist die AUG?
Gib AUG, AUG.
Jetzt wird's auch jedes Mal neu einstellen muss.
Moment, bin ich jetzt auf der anderen Seite?
Oh.
Gut, dann kein Night Mode für mich.
Vielleicht liegt's am Visier?
Das wäre aber sehr merkwürdig.
Also es wäre schon sehr merkwürdig, wenn man in einer Nachtmap kein Nachtvisier verwenden darf.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Okay, mal andere Night Time Server, mal andere.
Haben wir sonst noch einen?
Ja, nicht wirklich, oder?
Kiasa Railroad.
Nosha TDM Night Time.
Hast du einen, ich hab keinen Discord am Start.
Ach so, Origin.
Moment, wo schaltet man das noch mal aus?
Activate Origin in-game oder so, ne?
Oh, guck mal.
Es ist Nosha at Nacht.
Nosha at Nacht.
Komm, Leute, wir machen mal voll.
Lass mal drauf hier auf die Kiste.
Guck mal, hier haben wir auch einen guten Ping.
Der Typ hat einen Einser-Ping.
Steht der Server bei ihm unterm Tisch oder was?
Ich hatte alles aus und dann ist es das erste Mal gecrashed.
Dann hab ich es wieder angeschaltet.
Leute, wo hatte ich...
Warte mal, man hat das hier.
Da muss man auf Spieleigenschaft und Origin ausschalten, ne?
Mal gucken.
Ich hab ja die Vermutung, es liegt an Server beziehungsweise Map.
War da oben was?
Fuck man, Alter, du siehst ja nachts wirklich gar nichts, ey.
Du siehst ja nachts nichts.
Oh, Nearby Medics, das ist eine coole Anzeige.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ich mach jetzt einfach mein Infrarot-Visier wieder drauf.
Dann ist easy win.
Lulvee größer Kekwee, bester Name.
So sieht es aus.
Das ist ja auch richtig.
Es ist ja auch definitiv so, dass Lulvee größer Kekwee ist.
Das muss man auch mal anerkennen, Chat.
Es ist halt einfach so.
True, Lulvee.
Einfach die Wahrheit.
Ohne umschweife, es ist auch wirklich so.
Lulvee ist größer Kekwee.
Und ich geh sogar so weit, dass L u L größer Lulvee ist.
Allerdings ist Lulvee definitiv größer L u L und größer Kekwee.
Das ist schon mal klar.
Ich hoffe, ihr konntet mir folgen.
Ich seh nix.
Ich hab einfach mal in die Richtung gesprayt.
Hat funktioniert.
Einfach mal in die Richtung gesprayt.
Da kommt was.
What the hell.
Oka es.
Ich würde mal gerne wissen, wo hier was ist.
Da war was in der Mitte, ich hab's gesehen.
Ja.
Nee, das ist mein Dude.
Okay.
Ich mach hier nachher wirklich mal Infrarotwiese drauf.
rot visier wieder drauf du siehst ja sonst gar nichts hier aber infrarot mehr aber aber
aber ich denn die night maps das finde ich richtig nice hyper nice finde ich das
du verlierst voll deine gegner aus den augen weil es so dunkel ist
guckt euch das mal an du siehst die gegner ganz ich halte nur auf gut glück in die richtung
ich nehme ein bisschen night time gameplay auf ich mach das ihr wisst ihr was soll ich mache so ein
so ein mega clickbait die titel diesen battlefield 3 mod müsst ihr gespielt haben ausrufe zeichen
oder sowas ich brauche muni muni
ich brauche das gepär excellent kommst du raum
was lehrt alter was das für ein krasser immer dude ok gucken wir mal auf wo ist die aug
das ist ein geiler titel das mache ich ohne scheiß der titel ist so geil der ist die pure
verarschung von youtube nausea kennels gone dark gone wrong got gone sexual gone sexual
alter soll das hier lasst mich was bashen man über range sagt die aug
das ist der sucker ping dass man um die ecke gekillt wird aber da mache ich echt ein video zu das ist
mega nice ey leute es ist mega pock richtig pock nachtmodus massive pock ja klar leute soll ich
weiter wer will das mit der aug wer will dass ich auch spiele
das das vizier dauert halt ewig zum rein zu
monka es wo kam der dude her die rennen gerade voll in mich rein einfach so einfach so
einfach so ich nehme auf
ja da machst du nix die aug ist halt nicht so die ob war für den game
für den follow für den sub alles leider gerade ich gucken was try hat mode aktivieren zum
glück sitzt keiner zum glück sitzt keiner von den leuten irgendwie auf dem auf dem dach
lo daniel lull dankeschön 18 monate you save my ass aber so was von ss saved
nein die aug ist leer die aug ist leer es liegt auch wirklich dran hab doch gesehen wie
es am anfang mit m 16 ging so was von ab oder m4 16 aber die kombi das nacht vizier
stellt ist übelst ungewohnt aber man sieht die gegner schon besser muss man ja echt mal
sagen dass jeder das jeder da kam ein auge zudrücken
aber die nacht maps ich muss euch echt sagen es ist cool
es ist cool es ist schon es ist nice es macht echt
ich rüste mir dann noch an eine andere waffe im nacht sicht ausgleich hier los
hier hinten ist doch bestimmt irgendwas spawn doch garantiert das sporn reno hier
du kannst halt nicht so mit der aug nicht so drauf rushen und mit dem infrared visier
schon mal gar nicht mit dem infrared visier visier bist ja langsamer als meine oma beim
amen aber es macht bock der modus und das endlich mal endlich mal ist das was man muss
ja ehrlich sagen dieses visier hat ja normalerweise außer ein bisschen smoke keinerlei keinerlei
da seins berechtigung
aber so ist halt wirklich cool und wisst ihr was das geiles ist besser als der nachtmodus
von modern warfare der nachtmodus von modern warfare ist der ultra sack da dagegen ist
das hier echt huge watch out ok ok ok max ich muss mir dran gewöhnen dass man aug nicht
dauer spam kann aug dauer spray dauerfeuer ist nix aber es macht mega bock
massive nausea skills ja da ist er da guckt er erst raus von ihm
die night mode für bildschirme ok ich bin jetzt nicht so ganz sicher ob ich mich da
reintrauen kann
war doch was ich hab doch gerade was gesehen wo ist hier was andere seite andere seite
excellent excellent aber das geile ist halt auch an dem sound du hörst gegner in dem
spiel du hörst du hörst halt einfach gegner nicht so wie modern warfare wo du denkst
gegner zu hören und wirklichkeit hörst du gar keine und fällt euch mal auf wie geil
der sound ist von dem game auf kopf raus achtung die werden jetzt geholt
wie ist er da evaded ey massive big brain sidesteps
wow ok schon paar weihnachts snoops getroffen als würden weihnachts snoops wenn es an
leash spielen wenn ich da leash spiele noch nicht mal viele der guten leute
und vor der waffe erst ja ich rüste danach ohne scheiß ich mach danach mal ne aek danach
mach ich ne aek mit mit nachtsicht gerät du hast du kriegst halt one on ones kriegst
halt vergiss es mit der auke funktioniert nicht oh nice dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön
dankeschön dankeschön wow der hat mir der s gesaved habt ihr es gesehen aber massive
den hinter gerettet hat er mir alter das ist ja das ist eine wasserpistole jetzt werde
ich auch von der auke bashed aber das macht schon richtig spock leute so leute ich muss
jetzt mal kurz was anderes spielen ich kriege echt anfälle mit der waffe so also was was
mein loadouts okay okay easy easy
jawoll nachtsicht beste
man könnte einfach das gamma ein bisschen hochdrehen
einfach das gamma hochdrehen und und nachtsicht modus owen
warum werden die level im scoreboard nicht angezeigt gute frage nächste frage keine
ahnung weil weil es keine verbindung zum battle log hat wahrscheinlich denke ich mal
hinten war was guck mal alter wasserpistolen waffe
den damage das ding
wir haben jetzt versucht drei big brain outplayed
es hat sich hat sich gerade alles gegenseitig outplayed
ne okay also nachtsicht ich weiß ja nett ich glaube die gegner kommen jetzt auch drauf
klar dass kein nachtsicht ist also ich weiß nicht dass man kein nachtsicht braucht
hallo please easy
dafür ist nachtsicht pock nein oder sei wurde mittlerweile neues
battlefield ankündigt naja es wurde es wurde battlefield 6 ja schon geteasert vor einem
halben jahr oder so aber das war es
ha
jetzt ist es geil wie du mit nachtsicht durch alles durchgucken kannst ne richtig poggers
hyper poggers wow wo bin ich wo bin ich das ist echt gewöhnungsbedürftig dieser nacht
also vor allem dass das infrarot visier was passiert überhaupt
aber nice danke für die ganzen rettes leute
aber wir müssen wir müssen es mal ein bisschen abuse dass wir nachtsicht haben easy nachtsicht
hobs so schnell kannst du dich ja gar nicht bewegen mit dem nachtsichting
komm raus naja klar du kannst scheuen
ok nächste runde ist ist vorbei mit nachtsicht gibt es kein infrarot mehr oder doch doch
doch nächste runde gibt infrarot aber nächste runde nehme ich meine ak oder m16 oder m416
oder irgendwas
oh ich wollte messern fack oh null wie größer keck wie hat mich gebasht
denke noch rüber gezogen wie viele tickets hat eigentlich der server
wie viele tickets hatten das ok leute es ist auch auktime ist vorbei
nehmen wir durch
was hat mich denn da jetzt gerade m16 was aber ich krieg ich krieg so mega viele rettes
ey das ist nicht normal mancher muss es ja auch sein von vorteil sein da streamer zu
sein
aber wisst ihr was geil ist man kriegt halt ziemlich easy server voll
man kriegt halt ziemlich easy server voll jetzt einfach streamer machen server zeigen und
zack das ist das ding voll ne schon pock schon echt pock
was ist denn das überhaupt ist das 32 32 oder ist das 64 oder gar 100 irgendwas
easy jump
also norscher ist echt clusterfuck ich wollte eine ak klasse machen korrekt
loadout ne wir machen mal ne m416 und jetzt probieren wir mal das aus
aber das nachtsicht visier ich schon mal geil ich meine das ist total total underused ne
benutzt ja keiner
oh die famas in the cop ey bam ba ba bam
coole runde coole runde coole runde
das macht halt echt bock ne macht halt echt bock der night mode
und wie gesagt der video titel ich weiß jetzt schon norscher kennels gone dark gone wrong
gone sexual
es reicht weil ich es reicht weil ich einmal irgendwie keine ahnung mich irgendeiner t-bagged
hat oder so
wann kommt der nächste kobold stream ist das g-bait oder ist es ernst gemeinte frei ist
das g-bait oder war das ernst gemeint könnt ihr könnt ihr auch ernst gemeint sein
69 gg 420 69 gg glhf eats
props an die camper aber es macht wirklich bock ich hab nie großartig tdm gespielt also
ne norscher norscher tdm übrigens ich musste wir brauchen anderes perk wir brauchen suppression
perk also also anti suppression perk
kannst du dir vorstellen eigenen server zu machen ja klar
na klar kann ich mir das vorstellen mach ich auch sobald das halbweg stable läuft mach
ich das auch
sobald das halbweg stable läuft mach ich das
damit hat er nicht gerechnet dass der max darunter springt
ich glaube man braucht ihn nein nein nein nichts bock nichts bock ich wollte suppression rein
machen
ich glaube man braucht das nachtsichtdinger man kann das ganz normal wie auch am tag spielen
aber das macht es halt irgendwie aus
guckt euch mal an der ping der ping hier bist du um die ecke bam ba ba bam down ok customize
äh was hab ich gesagt wenn ich mach
nein nicht deploy
ich will cover cover will ich rein machen
ähm cover beste
und jetzt haben wir doppelt cover
da drüben steht jetzt komplette team auf dem dach
krass
what the hell von wo
wo sind sie
so mit der nachtsicht bis du musst du hier übelst rumscan abscan stels machen dass du
was siehst
ich hab keinen bock hier oben rum zu stelsen mit mit infrarot und so das ist
der kommt jetzt von hinten klein
oh weg withstand zaiger ein auto es kommen die auto shotgun
Jetzt wird zu viel los hier, jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch.
Krotter!
Taugt, taugt Support eigentlich im TDM?
Jetzt sagt Leute, ich hab nie TDM gespielt, großartig.
Ha, die respawnen so schnell.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Excellent, excellent.
Au, au, au, was ist das?
Ich brauch ne Waffe, weil ja, gib, gib.
Oh fuck, ich wollt mit der Rex so richtig ein rein drücken, ey.
Wo bin ich hier überhaupt gelandet gerade?
Alter, wo ist hier was los?
Moment, da oben war er, ich hab ihn genau gesehen, ich hab ihn genau gesehen, Alter.
Da ist er, äh, by the way, spotten geht nicht, spotten geht nicht, habt ihrs gesehen?
Spotten, ich hab den gespottet, hat nix gespottet.
Kommst du rum?
Näääh, so nicht, hinter uns, hinter uns, Alter, hier kannst du dich ja gar nicht bewegen.
Bewegen, unmögliche, da ist doch, da ist doch, da ist doch, stellts doch noch einer dahinter.
Oh, oh, oh, nice, schön weggesprayet, wird alles recorded, oh.
Ich kann mich noch an das beste Video von dir erinnern, das ich geschaut habe, da hast
du übelst geflamet wegen Dice, ja ich weiß.
Ich hab wahrscheinlich Dice wegen Suppression geflamed, oder?
Ich hab bestimmt wegen Suppression geflamed. Suppression war so eines meiner Lieblingsflame Themen in dem Game, ever.
Während ich stirb.
Wollte er mich messern, Kana?
Ich glaub der wollte mich messern.
Wo stirbt der Typ, Kana?
Boah, von der Seite voll mit der AK in die Frise. Dicefix diesen Scheiß heißt das, genau, ja.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern an das Video.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was auch sehr merkwürdig ist? Ich mein ich mach seit über zehn Jahren YouTube jetzt und ich kann mich an fast
jedes einzelne Video erinnern.
Also wenn ihr mir einen Video Titel sagt und ich mach das auf, ich kann euch ziemlich genau sagen,
um was es geht. Ziemlich gut, ziemlich gut.
Ich hätte, ich hätte mir das nie gedacht, dass ich mir das mal so merken würde, aber doch, ist so.
Tags.
Ich bin gerade übrigens sinnlos im Kreis gerannt, ne?
Boah, wie der ist nicht tot? Ernsthaft, der ist nicht tot gewesen?
Okay, Flank, Flank auf Doom, Alter. Massive Flank.
Aber ohne Scheiß diese Nachtsichtssache, das gibt dem Game echt so einen komplett neuen Aspekt.
Das finde ich richtiger, richtiger Hyper Poggers ist das.
Findet ihr den nicht auch?
Poggers Extreme.
Guck mal, da hat mich gerade gesehen und ich hab die Nachtsicht voll weggerotzt.
Oh, Kronx, ne Kronox, nicht Kronx. Aber Nightrush wäre auch cool.
Boah, fuck, das war zu viel, das war zu viel. Trinkst du viel an Weihnachten? Nee.
Eigentlich gar nicht, ich trinke so gut wie nix. Alter, what is happening? Hier sind es ja von allen Seiten.
Jetzt kann auch Kronx in den Titel gehen. Ich blicke nicht mehr durch, Leute. Es ist echt zu viel, was gerade abgeht.
Es ist echt zu viel los. Unlucky, unlucky. Unlucker. Kacke, Alter, wie sie weggesprayen wurden, hab das gesehen.
Massive Sprayer, Massive Wagsprayer. Hallo, ich will hier drüber.
Alter, die werden da krass weggesprayen. Nein, ich hätte nicht retzen sollen, ich hätte nicht retzen sollen.
Juckt dich das Corona-Gedöns überhaupt? Nein, nicht wirklich, also nicht großartig.
Was mich an Corona juckt, ist, dass ich mir ein bisschen Gedanken mache, was ist, wenn sich Leute anstecken.
Oder eventuell doch, um mich mache ich mir da wenig Gedanken, aber die soziale Sache stört mich nicht.
Wirklich, das ist mir vollkommen egal. Oh, jetzt wird sich angestellt.
Guckt euch mal an, die Stelzer, die Stelzer sind unterwegs.
Stels Mode Activated. Stels Mode Activated hier.
Das macht richtig Bock, Leute, ohne Scheiß. Das macht richtig, hast du noch Kontakt zu Kaboom?
Ja, ab und zu mal. Dank Corona besteht vielleicht sogar mal wieder die Chance, dass ich mit dem Fabian was aufnehme.
Man kann ja nicht so viel rumstelzen und hat Zeit. Jetzt meint er, warum er wieder angefangen hat Videos aufzunehmen.
Das hat bestimmt auch was damit zu tun. Echt heftig, wie Active Battlefield 3 noch ist.
Das ist ein Mod, das ist nicht das Offizielle. Aber das Offizielle ist auch Active.
Noch mal eine andere Nachtmap. Also Nachtmaps finde ich cool.
Vielleicht mache ich mir echt einen Server, Nightmaps Only, Nosha, Zen Crossing, Bazaar oder was auch immer es so gibt.
Ich gehe mal, Leute, ich wechsle mal den Server, ich gucke mal, ob es einen anderen Night Server gibt, anderen Maps.
Das sei denn, es kommt jetzt eine andere Map, aber das ist dann ja, glaube ich, Nosha Only.
Hallo? Postchamp? Postchamp?
Okay, ich glaube der Server ist gecrashed oder das Loaden funktioniert nicht oder sowas.
Wann kommt der nächste Fortran Stream? Nein, also ich habe mich jetzt schon zu Koboldbreit schlagen lassen, Leute.
Aber ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen und mal gucken, ob der schön aufgenommen hat.
Ich will nicht wieder was leaken.
Der hat nicht aufgenommen, Leute.
Ah, oder?
Doch, der hat doch aufgenommen.
Der heißt plus anders, guckt mal.
Der heißt plus, das heißt nicht Battlefield 3, das heißt einfach nur Client.
Das heißt einfach nur Client.
Shadowplayer, lul. Okay.
Ja klar, dann gucken wir mal, was es noch für Night Times Server gibt.
Zu Neujahr C++, ne, C++ haben wir schon öfters gemacht mit Microcontroller Kram.
Und freiwillig mache ich kein C++.
Okay, Filters, Tags, Nights.
Endlich mal was Neues hier in dem Game.
Okay, das ist, oh.
EpiSend.
Oh, hab ich nicht installiert? Okay.
Okay, jetzt erst mal gucken, wo wir den Kram mit Origin ausschalten.
Spiele Eigenschaften, Origin im Spiel leaktivieren, zack.
So, also, wie installieren, Zusatzinhalt, Zusatzinhalt, exzellent.
Ist Aftermath EpiCentrum?
Ich glaub schon, ne.
Ah, eine Minute, eine Minute, dann sind wir wieder am Start. Easy.
Easy.
Wo gibt's Battlefield 3 gratis? Wenn du Amazon Prime hast, kannst du die auf Twitch,
wenn du dein Amazon Prime Konto mit Twitch verknüpft,
kriegst du Battlefield 3 aktuell gratis bis 31. Dezember.
Und weißt du, Leute, Leute, soll ich aber sagen,
wisst ihr, was man noch gratis bekommt, wenn man in Battlefield,
äh, Quatsch, wenn man in Battlefield, wenn man Prime und Twitch verknüpft,
man bekommt einen Prime-Sub.
Das heißt, da könnt ihr mich gleich alle Prime subben.
Kostet euch nix.
Und für mich ist es wie jeder andere Sub auch.
Exquisite Subscriptions.
Any Primers.
Max, wollen wir nicht mal probieren, einen Rush-Server zu füllen?
Ich will als erstes nochmal eine Runde EpiCenter-Nighttime-TDM spielen.
Xenpy, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und Tyzix auch.
Massive Prime Subscriptions hier.
Ich wünsche dir die ganzen Subs.
Man muss das ab und zu mal ein bisschen bewerben, ja?
Ich mach das nie.
Oder zu selten.
Und man muss das einfach ab und zu machen.
Dance Gaming macht das richtig gut.
Dance Gaming, also ist ja in Abstand mein Lieblings-Let's-Player, ne?
Der baut das immer so richtig, so richtig weich in die, in seine Let's-Plays ein.
Nee, nee, nicht Battlelog starten. Wenn es an Leash starten.
Vielleicht haben wir auch demnächst mal ein paar mehr Emotes.
Ich hab ja noch 20 Emote-Slots frei, Leute, ne?
Aber ich glaub, der Patrick wollte mal auf Fiverr gucken.
Und da kriegen wir demnächst auch Emotes.
Oder ich kümmere mich selbst jetzt noch drum die nächsten zwei.
Äh...
Epicenter TDM, exzellent.
Findest du es nicht witzig, dass du im RL eher weniger sozial bist, aber auf Twitch so aktiv?
Ich mein, hier musst du ja auch ganze Zeit mit Leuten reden.
Nö, das ist totaler Unterschied.
Real Life werden dir irgendwelche Leute vorgesetzt, die dir auf den Sack gehen.
Und hier ist es ja so, ihr redet ja nicht mit mir, ich rede mit euch.
Und wir haben gewisserweise auch ein bisschen gemeinsame Interessen,
was man halt im Real Life nicht unbedingt so sagen kann.
Mir gehen halt im Real Life die Leute auf den Sack, weil die meisten Leute sind einfach total...
So richtig dumme Kacknoobs sind die Leute im Real Life. Die meisten.
Die meisten sind richtig dumme Kacknoobs.
Jetzt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, ich meine das mit dumm auch wirklich wörtlich.
Also es gibt im Real Life so unglaublich viel dumme Leute, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ah, null, guck mal Night Time.
Oh.
Infrarot-Visier, beste.
Habt ihr es gesehen, wie ich die geouten hab? Nur wegen dem Infrarot-Visier.
Alter, nur wegen dem Infrarot-Visier kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Kack, weh. Ich brauch, ich brauch Muni.
Hier, what? Was hab ich denn jetzt gekillt?
Arbeitest du im Kundensupport? Nein, glücklicherweise nicht, das wird schnell aushalten.
Kundensupport, Kundensupport ist ja Mord, Alter.
What is happening?
Alter, die Nightwish ist ja zu krass. Alter, wilder Scheiß.
Es ist, also aktuell ist es relativ stable, ja.
Aktuell ist es relativ stable. Okay, ich camp jetzt mal kurz hier.
Schmeiß mal den Nate hoch.
Komm, bestimmt gleich wieder.
Die Nightwish ist gerade so mega OP, ey, Lully.
Kommt runter, Leute, kommt runter. Ich warte auf euch, ich warte auf euch. Ja, ja, streckt den Kopf raus.
Komm her, komm her.
Okay, ich renn jetzt da hoch, easy.
Nein.
What the fuck? Alter, Battlefield, please.
Erst dreimal drüber springen und dann ihn nicht killen.
What the fuck war das denn jetzt?
Oh, wie er um die Enkel springt, wie er um die Enkel springt, mich einfach one-jotted.
Krasser Dude, krasser Dude.
Ich muss mit meiner Nightwish da rein, jawoll, jawoll.
Come on.
Nein, warum sollen wir irgendwelche Leute kicken?
Ich kick doch nicht random Leute, wahrscheinlich.
Ich mein, wer hier wirklich, also wer hier cheatet, ist wirklich selbst dran schuld.
Hier zu cheaten ist richtig pepega dumm.
Alles klar.
Okay, okay, die flanken, die flanken, bestimmt die flanken, die machen mächtiger Flanker.
Ich kenn die Map nicht, wo geht's hier lang?
Wo ist hier Flankerino?
Wo ist hier, wo ist hier, krasser Flankerstellz?
Da?
Das hast du dir so gedacht, Alter, das hast du dir so gedacht, Mann.
Ah, fuck.
M16, jawoll, jawoll, jawoll, M16.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Diese brenn, diese brenn Dinger sehen reudig schlecht aus.
Ah, shit.
Reds, please, please, please, Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds.
Nice, exquisite Reds.
Nur Big Brains schaffen den Reds.
Doch, Big Brain Flank, Massive Bra...
Scheiße, Mann, wo geht's hier lang?
Doch kein Big Brain Flank.
Konnte man die Dinger hier nicht kaputt machen auf Epicenter?
Epicenter war doch voll die Revolution Map.
Wo?
Was?
Der hat mich getroffen?
Wie hat der das denn gemacht?
Wie hat der mich denn durch den Boden, oder was?
Der Typ hat hinterm Stein gelegen, der konnte mich gerade treffen.
Okay, Battlefield, Netcode, Poggers, ähm.
Alter, hab ich sie geowned, ich hab sie doch ganz geowned, wieder die Kleinen.
Massive weggebashed.
Oh, ja, äh.
Das ist der Max, ja, korrekt.
So sieht es aus, das ist der Max.
Das ist der Max in Battlefield 3 mit Nightwish und OP-Modus aktiviert.
Massive Flank.
Alter, das Gelegge um die Ecke geht mir gerade auf den Keks.
Was wiederbeleben ist, ist echt das Beste an dem Game.
Mit das Beste, ich finde das mega nice.
Ja, da stirbt er einfach nicht.
Habe ich gedacht, na, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sterbe ich nicht, bleibe ich bei 1% HP.
Alter, wie ich den Kopf geballert habe.
Okay, wo kommen die jetzt her?
Achtung, wir machen jetzt Massive Flank.
Ich glaube, die kommen eher von da, ich glaube, die kommen eher von da.
Ja, ja, ja.
Guck, guck, guck, Leute.
Wisst ihr was?
Das macht so krass Bock.
Einfach, weil es was Neues ist und man mal Nachtsicht spielen kann.
Normalerweise kannst du nie Nachtsicht spielen in dem Game.
Niemand spielt Nachtsicht in dem Spiel, aber jetzt auf Nachtmaps richtig geil.
Das hätte DICE auch machen sollen.
Official Nightwish Mode.
Hier gibt es einen Pool, wusste ich gar nicht.
Jetzt kommen sie bestimmt von der anderen Seite.
Das geile ist halt, ich sehe die und die sehen mich nicht.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf, jetzt werden sie gebashed.
Guckt es euch an.
Hallo.
Okay, ich kriege noch nicht mal mehr Kills, ich weiß nicht warum, aber.
What?
Das mit Nightwish macht so Bock.
Okay, jetzt mal auf Flank.
Ich spiele einen neuen Modus, naja, also der Modus ist nicht neu, es ist TDM.
Aber es ist TDM, halt Nachtsicht TDM, was es halt im normalen Game nicht gab.
Ach ja, und ich kenne die Map nicht.
Das ist Epicenter TDM, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das im Original überhaupt gab.
Alles gecaptured.
Alles Capture Reno.
Okay, die kommen glaube ich jetzt eher von der anderen Seite.
Wo können wir hier geile Flankaction machen, können wir hier geile Flankaction machen?
Da fliegt er, da fliegt er, ich hoffe ich bin in Sicherheit geflogen.
Ja klar, alles klar, alles klar.
Sag mal, sind das neue Models, sind das die Hardline Models, die die da irgendwie drin haben oder gab es die vorher auch schon?
Wobei ich glaube am Game selbst dürfen sie ja nichts ändern.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt hier mal durch die Mitte, ich weiß nicht wo es da raus geht, aber beste.
Äh, okay.
Nein, ich hatte so einen schönen Flank.
Ah, shit.
Was?
Shit, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen, mit der Aug, mit der Aug, der ersten Dest ging in der Aug.
Der kommt hier rein, ich sag's euch.
Okay, nicht schnell genug rüber gezogen.
Also gerade jetzt gibt's auf den Sack, die holen auf, holen die auf, seh ich das richtig?
Geh ich nass?
Die Gegner holen auf.
Wobei ich glaube wir haben bessere Gegner einfach jetzt, sind wahrscheinlich seine wieder nachgejoint.
Leute, wieder nachgejoint, ist ja auch richtig so, ist ja auch gut.
Der haut rein.
Okay, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen langsamer das Ganze mal machen.
Ist das ein endlos, sehr endlos Kill Server oder ist das irgendwann auch mal, ist auch irgendwann mal die Runde vorbei?
Was?
Von der anderen Seite?
Ah, 500 Tickets.
What?
Battlefield, please?
Lass mich da drüberspringen, Alter.
Das Game verwirrt mich gerade.
Also manche, manche die seh ich kaum und across the map.
Oh, ich wurde gerätzt, sehr gut.
Exquisite Resurrection.
Defi, exquisite Defi.
Einfach mal 20er KD raus, ich hab doch 20er KD, guck mal.
51 13, das ist doch eindeutig 20er KD.
Alter, please.
Ich hör was.
Lol, das habt ihr euch so gedacht.
Okay, Stells Modus.
Jetzt ist ja mal gut.
Der hat bestimmt auch Nightwishen jetzt.
Okay, ich sollte mal ein bisschen weniger hier oben rum.
Hallo, darf ich mal durch, nope.
Okay, jetzt haben wir uns alle ein bisschen festgesetzt, wie es aussieht.
Bin ich ganz sicher von wo?
Ich weiß nicht so genau von wo, von wo?
What, von, hä?
Wo ist der Dude?
Okay, ich hab die Shit keine Ahnung, wo hier gerade was ist.
Viper.
Okay, wir gehen mal kurz woanders hin.
Ist der Infrarot kaputt?
Nope.
Oh, da hat er gewartet.
Big Brain Typ.
Da siehst du, die Gegner sind jetzt mittlerweile gescheit.
Auf die andere Weise, wäre der einfach weiter gerusht, er hätte das überhaupt nicht kapiert.
Ja, M16 ist halt...
Ops-Fuck.
Da steht er einfach drin
Ich fasse es nicht
Da steht er, da steht er einfach
Einfach, einfach, wird einfach da gestanden
Mann, lasst mich in Ruhe, mann
Lasst mich euch einfach abstelzen
Lasst mich euch doch einfach mal mit meiner Nightwishen bashen
Warum, warum, warum nicht?
Das ging doch am Anfang auch so schön
Aber gut, da waren es ja auch noch keine Kacknoob-Gegner
Äh, da waren es ja auch noch Kacknoob-Gegner
Achtung, jetzt wird rumgestellt
Der Massive-Stells-Action
Hier ist nichts da
Da war er, da war er, ich hab ihn gesehen
Bam, nice
Oh
Ey, der Night-Modus
macht richtig Bock, ey
Ich kann nicht mehr TDM
Wir können mal gucken, ob wir einen Rush-Night-Server
oder so voll kriegen
Dam Jam, du kannst aber
Venice Unleashed spielen
Weil, das hat gar
kein Anti-Cheat
Der
Banden-Button geht nicht
Der ist einfach, oh jetzt doch, ist einfach
Jebait
Venice Unleashed hat kein
Anti-Cheat, also das kannst du aber ohne
Punkbuster spielen, aber dass du
Punkbuster dich rauswirft, liegt wahrscheinlich
daran, dass du nicht richtig installiert hast, du musst bei deinen Installationen
reparieren und in die Windows-Services
gehen und sagen
Punkbuster starten, das ist ein
Trick
Ok, ähm
Rush
Metro-Night-Time
Metro-Night-Time, was ist denn der Unterschied?
Ich mein, erste Base und letzte Base
Nee
Aber das ist der einzige Rush-Server, den es gibt
Leute, hier
Beer and Rush
Night-Time, Kompass
Gucken, was wir da für einen Ping haben
Nice Mad Dog
Excellent, also
Du kannst ja mal die Video-History angucken
Es ist total random, ne, also
Wir machen von Programmier-Streams bis
Battlefield-Streams bis irgendwelchen
Laberstreams, alle möglichen Sachen, wie es mir grad
danach ist, also
100%
Battlefield-Content kann ich nicht machen
Zu stressig
Ich hoffe
Leute, könnt ihr euch vorstellen
Ich bin so scharf drauf, dass
Battlefield 6 was taucht
Ohne Spaß
Ohne Scheiß
Ok, 140er Ping
Wollen wir es trotzdem mal probieren
Der einzige Rush-Server, der geht
50 Tickets, das ist ja nichts
Weil der Delay
Achso, 50 Sekunden, weil ich nicht will, dass mich einer
Streams snipe, und jetzt sag nicht, das passiert nicht
Ich hatte es oft genug
Ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass
wirklich gestreams sniped wird, aber
Tja
Leider, leider
Nein Max, was nein
Oh, was jetzt
Neuer Rush-Server mit 10 Millisekunden
ist in ein paar Sekunden da
Excellent
Tja, dann, dann warten wir mal auf den neuen Server
Servers
Filter, Night-Time
Rush
Game Mode
Der da?
Du
Hi, eh du
Wisst ihr übrigens, was der Typ da sagt?
Das passt zu Weihnachten, der sagt Jesus
Ist kein Witz, guckt euch den Untertitel an
Der sagt Jesus auf Spanisch, der Typ
Jetzt
Das soll Jesus heißen auf Spanisch
Er kennen übrigens noch nicht mal Spanier
Er kennen doch nicht mal Spanier
Rush
Ah, der hier?
Excellent, auf gehts
Und wie, da hab ich jetzt keinen Fünferping
Sagt der nicht, also in den Untertitel sagt der Jesus
Vielleicht sind auch die Untertitel kacke
Oh guck mal
Damn Event Peak Night-Time
Massive nice
Man muss ja mal sagen
Night-Time Maps
Guckt mal, seht ihr mal
Wie geil
Dem Event Peak Nachts aussieht
Richtig gut
Ich baller übrigens mal nicht auf den Heli
Wie geil das Nachts aussieht, ey
Als wäre es dafür gemacht, ey
Moment, geht ihr runter?
Moment, geht die Runde schon los?
Warte mal, die Runde geht schon los
Warum geht die Runde schon los, Alter?
Warum geht die Runde schon los?
Weil wir erst nachdem acht Leute drin sind
Habt ihr gesehen, man kann nicht durch die Fenster gucken
Nachts, weil es zu dunkel ist
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool
Du
Richtig nice
Exzellent, exzellent
Alter, gehst fort mit deinem Kackeli
Ich mach jetzt gleich Igla-Stells
Vielleicht gibt es Igla-Stells, ey
Ich sag euch, der hat den Server nur gemacht, dass er uns mit dem Heli ownen kann
Lull, schreckt, smockt
Was auch immer das sein soll
Hab ich mir gerade ausgedacht, das Wort
Nice
Ich würde ja mit reingehen, aber zum retten
Fuck, Alter
Was, 120 Euro im Monat?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Hä?
What the...
What the fuck, wo sind die alle?
Ey du
Ich hab einen Fallschirm draußen gehabt
Ihr habt es gesehen
Hat das Game aber nicht interessiert
Game hat es gedacht, nope
Oh shit, shit, shit
Shit, please, please, please, please, please
Nice
What the fuck
Können die sich mal normal bewegen?
Das ist ja ein Rumgezuckel hier, so nachs Gleichne
Was ist da?
Stellsten wir da gerade drin rum?
Ey du
Was ist mit den Gegnern gerade los ey?
What the fuck?
Instant rekt
Balance
Alter, balance please
Ja, ich trille euch auch gleich ein US Hauler
What ist hier los, Alter?
Gegner OP, please, nerf
Cheat, cheat
Alles cheat
Natürlich, guck dir das mal an, muss alles cheat sein
Kann nicht sein, dass wir irgendwie jetzt hier verlieren
Das ist cheat
Easy cheat, easy live
Oh
Wir sind ganz schön im Aus
Lul
Keine gute Idee
Wir kriegen aber auch nichts geschissen gerade
So, das müssen wir, das müssen wir ein bisschen besser, besser
Mischen gleich
Oh, da ist er, da ist er, da ist er am Start hier, da ist er am Start hier
Ey, wie viel 30 Milliarden Gegner hier am Start sind
Ist das Wahnsinn
Die aufen, ich hab Shadowplay immer rückwirkend an
Warum sind eigentlich die Squads so riesengroß gerade?
Wir haben einen Fünfer und einen Sechser Squad
Aber nur vier Leute unten drinne
Äh
Häh
Ok, das, das ist
Nicht, nicht so ganz
du
Aber wir haben es wir haben es da ist taugt das update was ja es ist ja kein update in dem
sind es eigentlich mod pack also sprich das game am game am basic game hat sich jetzt
erstmal von dais seite aus nichts geändert aber nice aber es gibt halt viele community
änderung sehr nice ist hallo game please springt in der mitte auf der gas auf der gas ist doch
einer quitt fucking around ja denke ich mir auch so grad
quitt fucking around
ihr dürft bei mir spawnen leute
spawnen bei mir spawnen bei mir leute easy das stream sniper ist da
nice nice und jetzt jetzt aber fast aber gut gemacht
oh nee wir sind wieder sind wir sind dead jetzt wird schwierig da kann mir eigentlich mal
irgendjemand erklären was ich da ist dabei gedacht hat es hat schon dieser base schon öfters was
ich da ist dabei gedacht hat dass die defender hier in den heli kriegen
ne das ist nicht der an das ist das ist der man peak bei nacht eigentlich richtig massive big
join mal bitte die telegram gruppe was gibt es denn in der telegram gruppe werde ich dann
reich in 14 tagen oder sowas also ist ja das mindeste was man mal machen kann ja
oder kommt da da kommt da aber geht das spot nicht bei der way
ist das spotten ist das spotten irgendwie defekt
ich sehe nämlich null gespottene gegner
aber das spotten geht nicht oder kann das sein was denn das hier
wo ist der dann
okay wir müssen diffusen nicht diffusen defenden
jetzt haben sie diffusen ich fasse es nicht
ich iglar jetzt gleich den heli runter
was schon wieder diffusen
wie sind die dann gerade alle gestorben
das game alter
hab das game gerade gesehen wie es nicht ging
wie es einfach nicht funktioniert hat das ding zu killen
er ist nicht weg
Die sind aber auch scharf, die Gegner!
Ich verstehe, also wie gesagt, also eins habe ich bei DICE jetzt hier noch nicht nachvollziehen
können. Wie haben die es geschafft oder warum haben die hier einen Heli eingebaut für die
Defender? What? Ich war schon längst wieder unten! Kopf rausgestreckt, weggefurzt! Ah,
nice! Aber der Nachtmodus ist so geil! Der Nachtmodus ist Massive Poggers! Massive Poggers!
Tick Rates, ja. Das sind halt so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, ey, warum hatten das DICE
nicht schon zu normalen Zeiten gemacht, ne? Oh, wir haben Lee gehändet. Oh Mist, ich wollte
ratzen. Massive, ja. Ne, ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Warum hat DICE manche Sachen
davon noch nicht gemacht, ähm, als das Game eben rausgekommen ist oder? Gut, ich glaube,
die wollten Serverinfrastruktur sparen. Okay, manpower, manpower, pausechamp, pausechamp.
Oh, das Infrarotvisier ist so geil durch den Smoke. Wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob man Smoke gucken kann. Kann man Smoke gucken? Ah, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen. So ein
bisschen Smoke kann man gucken. Ah, das war natürlich kein Headshot. Nice, wir haben den
Healy, excellent. Jetzt, ich ratze! Nice. Okay, Massive Push. Okay, ich nehme mal auf.
Einfach nur, dass man ein paar Szenen hat für ein Video. Warum haben die nie wieder
so geile Sachen im Battlefield hingekriegt danach? Wie zum Beispiel so ein Sprung hier
von, von, von, von dem Berg, ja. Zu geil. Massive Crayon Gazzamer. Woah, ey! What the
hell? Wieso, wie viel hält denn der Dude aus? Sechs Prozent, alles klar. In die Bobbes
geschossen, in die Füße geschossen, drauf geschossen und dann Bam, in den Kopf getappt.
Über uns ist irgendein Dude, oder?
Pass mal auf, beste Posi auf der ganzen Map hier vorne. Hier, hier ist die beste Posi
auf der ganzen Map. Fuck man, aber natürlich nicht, wenn man Healy im Ass hat. Die Posi
ist richtig geil, aber natürlich so nicht. Guck mal hier, Mr. Army geht ja mal richtig
ab. Warum geht Mr. Army so krass ab? Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen? Ne, äh,
was ist? Ne, das ist.
Kannst ja mal probieren. Ach Moment, hier ist ja alles down schon.
Zu spät. Bam. Oh, da war sogar zu früh.
Erstmal den Healy abfacken, das macht ja keiner sonst.
Mann, Kackmesser-Animation, geh mal ein bisschen schneller. Sag mal, ist der Healy-Stelzer schon
wieder da? Ist der Healy-Mann schon wieder am Start? What the fuck? What is happening?
Ey, what, was ist denn hier los? Gespräche, wie verrückt die Gegner und der beste One-Shotted
von irgendwas. P9 und Side, ach Quatsch, P9, Side und Side, Champ. Guck mal, die One-Shotted
mich alle. Was ist denn hier los? Stehst hier auf, kriegst den Kopf vorne geschottet.
Alles Cheater, alles Cheater. Confirmed. Cheat-confirmed, easy. Muss, muss. Kann ich sagen, wenn es kein
easy-win ist, dann ist es eindeutig cheat-confirmed. Man kennt das, man kennt das. Okay, wir gehen
jetzt in den Panzer rein. Sobald der Panzer spawnt, oh fuck. Nein, Alter, ich will den
Panzer. Also, ich will Gunner und ich will retten. Wisst ihr, Ami, wir können den Panzer
klein, wenn er, wenn er spawnt. Geht einer mit mir rein? Auf, ich muss, ich muss Rapper-Dude
machen. Ich habe mein Equipment für den Panzer nicht. What? Ist kein Panzer-Equipment ausgerüstet.
Kein Zoom und nichts. Na, geil. Alles, guck mal, ist es, sag mal, ist der Panzer falsch
gekommen oder so? Michael Wendler bedankt sich für den Stream, excellent. Ich komme
rein. Ich habe keinerlei Equipment, das ist mein Problem. Ich habe kein Equipment, ich
habe weder Zoom noch irgendwas. Okay, alles. Hinter mir, Rotte. P90 Ironside, Spray-Champ.
Oh, get schreckt. Get schreckt. Ist mir egal, ob du mich RPGt hast. Ja, also ich habe aber
kein Panzer-Loadout. Ich weiß gar nicht mal, wo man den Scheiß überhaupt einstellt. Customize,
excellent. Doch, ich habe noch ein Panzer-Loadout, aber das ging nicht. Okay, auch gut, auch gut.
Muss man nicht verstehen. Okay, wir können jetzt auf B pushen irgendwie, so schnell wie
es geht. In der Hoffnung, die können B nicht... doch, fuck. Guckt es euch an, wie sie einen
One-Shot nähen und alle irgendeinen OP-Shit spielen. Okay, muss ich auch mal wieder switchen.
Auch mal OP-Shit wird Zeit. Easy OP-Shit, easy. Oh, kleine Legehände da vorne. Komm,
retz mich, ich bin hinter dir. Throne. Thronstells. Ey, jetzt Leute, wisst ihr, was wir brauchen?
Jetzt bräuchten wir den Typ, den ich letztens gehostet habe. Hat das einer noch ein bisschen
geguckt, den ich letztens gehostet habe? Der ist richtig geil, der Typ. Auch mit Smoke
und allem, der ist richtig gut. Oh, da ist ein Panzer. Direkt vor mir. Okay, nice. Nein,
da steht er. Panzer, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer. Lol. Ich verarsche den Panzer jetzt ein bisschen.
Okay, das sollten wir haben. Hallo, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer. Lol. Wir sollten
es glaube ich gleich haben. Warte mal, ich blicke null durch, was hier gerade abgeht.
Absolut gar nicht mehr. Es ist voll vorbei, dass ich durchblicke. Ich habe es komplett
aufgegeben, durchblicken zu wollen. Pepega, Feuer. Ja genau, als den ich gehostet habe,
er macht richtig nice Infanterie-Aggressive-Smoke-Gameplay. Und spielt so ziemlich jede Waffe. Oh, oh, oh.
Ist der Typ down? Scheiße. Und spielt auch fast jede Waffe richtig gut. Risch Poggers.
So. Oh. Pants Man. Oh, Doppel, Dual, Dual Pants Man am Start. Exquisite Pants Man. Die
letzte Base kann echt schwer sein, aber die Gegner verkacken es wahrscheinlich. Easy.
Oder wir verkacken es. Hallo, Geh. War ich da jetzt nicht drauf, oder war das Battlefield-Logik?
Ich war bestimmt nicht drauf. In the ass-shooted.
Was war denn das für ein Kack-Versucher? Mist, den habe ich zu spät gesehen. Jawoll.
Wachsinger, lass mich respawn. Respawn, please, please. Nein, ich sterbe, ich sterbe, ich
sterbe. Respawn, respawn, respawn, respawn, respawn, respawn. Nein. Brain-Lag. Brain-Lag,
ich habe das gesehen, er ist gestorben. Ich hätte es sehen müssen und dann Bäm, habe
ich auf respawn gedrückt. Richtig kacknubisch. Richtig kacknubs. So wieder richtig. Als hätte
ich das Spiel zum ersten Mal gespielt, ja. 5 Mann, es ist teilweise ein 7 Mann Squad oder
so etwas ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Oh, oh, huge, huge. Alter, sagen wir mal, machen die gerade
best den Streamer? Was machen die denn? Ich, ich komme ja keine, ich bin ja keine 2 Sekunden
am Leben. Jawoll, in die Fresse geballert, so muss das sein. Ok, jetzt fahren wir, wir
fahren Panzer. Fahren jetzt Panzer, easy. Easy Pantsman am Start. Hab ich jetzt mein
Loadout? Ja, jetzt habe ich mein Loadout. Ok, jetzt wird gepusht. Ah.
Wie, das hat den nicht gekillt?
Disabled?
ja wohl jetzt aber als er dauernd
war das knapp
wo man
wir müssten es jetzt eigentlich haben wir haben es meine güne war das anstrengend
ey fuck alda oh fuck my life das war echt anstrengend gg eats jetzt wenn man
gewonnen hat ihr wisst wie das ist wenn man gewonnen hat ist es ja prinzipiell
prinzipiell easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
okay genug es kommt jetzt wie findet ihr wenn es die nachtmaps sind wirklich
nice wo haben die wo haben die ihre server steht stehen dieser anbieter
leute wenn es sich irgendwie eine wahnsinns geile map kommt höre ich auf
mir reicht es mir reicht auch noch mal den bewend pick halte ich dann aus
leute ich bin morgen wieder am start gleich als server kann man machen
vielleicht miete ich mir auch ein
frankfurt nice also kett 24 du kannst den ruhig du kannst den ruhig runterfahren
oder wie auch immer man das bei welchem anbieter du bist das machen muss dass es
weniger oder nichts kostet oder löschen und morgen oder übermorgen wenn ich im
stream bin kannst du machst du einfach wieder an oder ich hole mir ein oder ich
hole mir ein wie heißt der anbieter noch mal gucken wir
gerade mal was der kram kostet wenn es an liegst server
irgendwas mit active oder so ja ja wir an michael ventler im gegner team sagt
euch kommt danach in die whatsapp gruppe seid ihr seid ihr auch in der michael
ventler gruppe und natürlich und natürlich auch in der in der wie heißt
dieser andere typ es gibt du hast du diese drei typen
du hast den ventler du hast saffi naidu und du hast dings hier wie heißt denn
der der koch übelst bekehr ich komme jetzt gar nicht drauf
ja ist er du ich mir fällt es nicht ein der vegane koch ja da muss da alle alle
immer in die gruppe ja in die gruppe da lernt man wie die welt aussieht atilla
hilf ja der genau den mein ich nicht demelzer demelzer
demelzer genau atilla hildemann
oder hildemann oder wie auch immer
ich würde ohne scheiß leute wüsste ich würde wirklich gerne in diese gruppen
nicht weil ich jetzt sage ja so ist es sondern weil ich das lustig finde ich
ich gucke mir auch permanent irgendwelche im mainstream medien debunked
und so zeug auf youtube an ich finde ich finde das übelst lustig aber ich kann
da nicht rein weil ich kein whatsapp habe die haben doch haben die haben die
der ventler hat eine telegram gruppe oder oder ist das alles telegram
ich habe da gar keine ahnung von also wie ist die server noch mal die man sich
mieten kann hier alliance apps
was hat was war das jetzt für 32 spieler
was war das für den server was hattest du denn für ein und auf wie viel tix war
der server gestellt
24 max betreibt die dinger übrigens achso
die gehört der lander exzellent
das ist ja auch nicht so
so die gehört der lander exzellent exzellent ja
das war der 35 euros aber ok hat sie den hat sie den auf 120 tick laufen ich
habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt
die ketet high performance score ja so die anderen klauze ich aber ich habe mir
auch überlegt da musste ich mir entweder bei der hets nach surfer auktion einholen
und ganz ehrlich das ist auch nicht so viel billiger du brauchst halt was mit
ordentlich single core performance oder 60 ja immer noch besser als 30
ich glaube ich glaube ich hole mir dann auch ein ich hole mir auch ein muss ich
gucken ob es noch irgendwelche schönen plug ins gibt also die klassischen
dinger also wie bet auto balance und sniper limit und sowas
mach ich einen poch rush server
ach der kram muss ja wind auslaufen wir laufen das unter wein mittlerweile ich
habe gehört dass wein geht aber irgendwie nicht so ported ist oder sowas
ich habe ein paar server schon dabei einlaufen sehen wobei weil wir wieder
strebt es halt echt in den windows server zu holen
letztendlich hier ist es egal da ist es ja unter der haube
ich glaube ich probiere das mal aus ja leute also falls ihr es auch nicht
wusstet
bis 31.12 gibt es noch battlefield 3 umsonst auf twitch wenn ihr amazon prime
habt müsst ihr das ganze verknüpfen mit eurem twitch account und dann könnt
ihr battlefield 3 kostenlos runterladen bis ende des jahres und einlösen
ihr könnt den könnt euch den key holen bis ende des jahres und einlösen bis
ende januar wenn ihr gerade schon dabei seid und eh schon
eure prime account gerade mit twitch verknüpft dann könnt ihr auch einfach
auf twitch gehen und dann geht ihr dahin und dann und dann drückt ihr da drauf und
dann wenn ihr darauf geklückt habt könnt ihr kostenlos subscriben
dann habt ihr hier oben anstatt 499 steht dann drin use prime sub da könnt ihr
mich einmal kostenlos subscriben für mich ein ganz normaler sub euch kostet
es nix und ihr kriegt ein paar emotes demnächst gibt es mehr emotes ich habe
noch 20 oder 24 emotes slots frei
wir sind dabei ja
exzellent
war echt anstrengend unter weinen ist nix ok na dann dann muss doch windows sein
du musst nicht läffeln in battlefield 3 ich glaube du hast alles freigespielt in
wenn es anliegt
wenn du bei einem key shop das game holst dann
achso premium key ne ne ne ne ne das geht nicht aber was kosten der kram kostet
doch nix mehr
ich doch in der heck schmissen
watta fuck maybe later was them
und mich weappeln
ernsthaft
gibt es compliments
Ich habe es hier nicht.
Achso, ja die Premium Edition ist dabei, da ist alles inklusive DLCs glaube ich.
Oder, ne da ist ein Premium Pass dabei.
Also 13 Euro, das ist eigentlich ganz schön teuer, ne?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Gibt es doch am Software Kong was?
Okay.
Key for Steam.
Okay auf diese Seiten gehe ich nicht drauf, das mache ich nur aus meiner VM.
Wer weiß was du da wieder für komische russische Viren oder so kriegst.
MMOGA Premium 750, okay.
Ja also müsst ihr mal gucken, es gibt es schon an vielen Stellen ziemlich günstig.
Ich gucke jetzt mal beim Software Kong.
Beim Software Kong habe ich mir letztens eine VMWare Lizenz gekauft.
Software Kong, bester Ladenname überhaupt ja, Battlefield 3, so also wo gibt es das zu
kaufen?
Wie?
Ich habe es doch eben G2A gesagt, ich habe es nicht gefunden, G2A, also easy, easy life.
G2A 1,71 Euro.
Oh Country?
Kann aktiviert werden in Germany.
Ja easy.
Ja also 1,71 Euro, das ist schon ganz schön, ganz schön viel ja.
Also ich meine 1,69 wäre okay, aber 1,71 ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay Leute, nice das ihr alle am Start wart, vielleicht mache ich mir morgen oder übermorgen
noch einen Server oder der Cat24 startet wieder ein.
Ja, was habt ihr eigentlich sonst noch wo wir gerade dabei sind, kann man ein bisschen
Werbung machen.
Alliance Apps, Arma 3, okay, also altes live, das war mal, altes live war mal vor so 2 Jahren
voll der Hype, ich glaube das spielt gar keiner mehr oder, na war mal doch dreieinhalb Stunden
und alles Leute, machts gut wir sehen uns, bis morgen oder übermorgen, wahrscheinlich
morgen, morgen ist ja auch noch Weihnachten, da habe ich Zeit.
Ihr habt ein Aircontool für Venice Unleashed entwickelt, ach nice, ich dachte das ist
standardmäßig in Battlefield schon dabei, nee Quatsch, kann ja standardmäßig nicht
in Battlefield dabei sein, weil man den offiziellen Battlefield Server ja nicht hat.
Stimmt, habe ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht, das muss man ja auch nachbauen, ja weil ich
brauche auf jeden Fall einen Auto Balancer und einen Sniper Limit, sonst hält man das
teilweise gar nicht aus.
Aber das ist alt und gammelig, ich werde es ja mal angucken, also Leute wir sehen uns
machts gut, bis denn, CU, achso wir brauchen auch Outro Musik, Outro, alter ich kann halt
nicht, Outro Musik, bis denn, CU.